Are you
Hey
darling.
Hallelujah.
All right. The next one we will discuss
over here, the next lecture is an
advocate for our time.
And it's a provocative picture that we
have over here with the tables of stone
and the finger of God in the background.
Well, Exodus 31:18 says, "And he gave
unto Moses when he had made an end of
communing with him upon Mount Si two
tablets of testimony, tables of stone
written with the finger of God." So God
wrote in stone the ten commandments. He
wrote them with his own finger.
Exodus 32:16 says, "And the tables were
the work of God, and the writing was the
writing of God graven upon the tables."
Now in fact there are only three times
in the Bible
when God wrote, and all three times he
wrote with his finger.
That's this one. Exodus 32:16. God wrote
the Ten Commandments in stone with his
finger.
Jesus wrote in the sand with his
>> finger. And when Babylon was about to
fall, the hand wrote with a finger
against the wall. So that's fascinating.
God wrote himself three times and every
time it was with his finger. And when
Moses had smashed these tables because
the children of God had apostasized
while he was on the mount, Deuteronomy
10:2 says, "And I will write on the
tables the words that were in the first
tables." God says, "Make another set of
tables which thou breakest, and thou
shalt put them in the ark."
So the tables of the testimony
containing the ten commandments written
with the finger of God were placed
inside the ark.
Right now let us first define the
question of sin. It's very important
that we know where we stand on these
issues because there are many teachings
in the world out there and we want to
stay Biblebased.
1 John 3:4, "Whosoever committh sin
transgresses also the law, for sin is
the transgression of the law." Is that
pretty plain?
So if you transgress God's
law, then you are committing sin. So if
I steal, do I transgress God's law?
>> Yes. If I do anything contrary to God's
law by definition of the New Testament,
then I'm sinning. That's the New
Testament. People like to say, you know,
the law was for the Old Testament, but
the definition is in the New Testament
as to what constitutes sin. We look at a
dictionary as to what transgression is.
It's a stepping over to transgress, the
act of transgressing, the breaking or
violation of any law.
So if you're going to transgress, there
must be a law. Romans 4:15 says, "Where
no law is, there is no transgression."
That's fascinating. So Adam and Eve, did
they have a law?
>> Yes.
>> They must have had a law otherwise they
couldn't have transgressed.
>> Now, can God's law change? You think
>> it's written in stone? Does that say
something? It's written in stone.
Now man can change laws but God's law
doesn't change. You know in South Africa
where I come from they had some strange
laws in our country some weird laws and
they've been changed. In the past there
was a law which was called the
immorality act. And if a white man was
in the company of a black lady or vice
versa
then uh that was problematic. you could
go to jail. Today that law is rescended,
it is no more and it's no problem.
So you see, you can either remove the
law to remove the problem or if the law
stands, well then if you break it,
you're a transgressor, right or wrong.
Okay? So if the if there's no law, there
can be no transgression. And Romans 6:23
says the wages of sin, which we've just
defined by the Bible, is transgression
of the law. So we could read it. The
wages of transgressing of God's law is
>> death. So this is an important issue.
Some people say there is no law. We
cannot keep the law. But the Bible
clearly teaches that if we transgress
God's law, well the wages are sin or
death.
Now sin separates from God. Let's read
that. Isaiah 59:E2.
Your iniquities,
that's your sins, have separated you
from your God.
That's important. Some like to turn this
definition upside down. I prefer to keep
the definition as the Bible says it. Sin
is the transgression of the law. And if
you sin, that causes separation.
So, we've been separated from God
because of sin. But there is a means of
resolving the problem. and that means is
Christ. Romans 6:23, for the wages of
sin is death, but the gift of God is
eternal life through Jesus Christ our
Lord. So now two possibilities,
Adam and Eve sinned
and the wages of sin is
>> death.
two possibilities
either we do away with the law like in
South Africa there was a law it was a
stupid law so they did away with the law
there is no more law and so if there is
no more law
>> then there is no more transgression does
that make sense
>> so if we take away the law that solves
the problem then you're free and
everybody who was in jail because of the
immorality act was set free. Off you go.
There is no more law. So, you're no
longer in transgression. You're free.
Did Christ do that.
Did he set aside the law? Yes or no?
>> No.
You see, the law said, "You will die."
So, Christ could have said, "Oo, I made
a law, but that law is too tough for you
fellows. So, let's just take the law
away." But God doesn't change. So now we
have an impass. The law says you will
surely die.
But Christ did not deal with the issue
lightly. Had he been had it been
possible for him to take away the law,
would it then be necessary to pay the
penalty of the law? Yes or no?
>> No. So in other words, the fact that
Christ came and died means he paid the
penalty. Right or wrong?
>> Does the law then still stand? Yes or
no?
>> Yes.
>> Absolutely.
So some people like to say the cross
does away with the law. I would like to
tell you the cross is the guarantee that
the law stands.
>> Amen.
The cross is the guarantee that the Lord
that the law stands because had it been
possible to take the law away then
Christ need not have died. Does that
make sense?
>> Okay.
I will put enmity, you remember that
text, between thee and the woman and
between thy seed and her seed and he
shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel. Genesis 3:15. There
would be enmity between the devil and
Christ. For by grace you are saved
through faith, and that not of yourself.
It is a gift of God's, not of works,
lest any man should boast.
Is that confusing or is it not? No, it's
not confusing.
Can I be saved by keeping the law?
>> No.
>> No. I am saved by
>> grace. Christ paid the penalty for me
and he died for me and by grace I am
saved. If I accept the gift of salvation
I am saved by grace. The law cannot save
me. The law is just writing. The law is
not a means to save me. The law is just
a means of telling me what is right and
wrong. Does that make sense?
>> All right.
For sin shall not have dominion over
you. For you are not under the law but
under grace.
What then shall we sin because we are
not under the law but under grace? What
does Paul say there? God forbid.
In other words, what he's saying here is
grace saves me
and works cannot save me but sin must
not rule over me. transgression of the
law must not be part of my life.
So because grace saves me, what then?
Shall I now be able to sin? Yes or no?
God forbid.
Grace establishes the law. I look to the
cross and I say, "Wow, Lord, why did you
have to suffer for me and die?" And the
Lord says, "Because you are a
transgressor and the law requires that
you die. Therefore, I pay the price for
you and the justice has been done.
Justice has been done. Let me give you
an example.
If you have a little daughter, if you
have a little daughter, some guy comes
along, rapes her, beats her up,
mutilates her, strangles her, and leaves
her lying there dead.
Wow. And you're
crushed. absolutely devastated
and you go to court
and the judge says, "Now that was not a
nice thing to do. Please see to it that
you don't do it again." Off you go.
>> How would you feel?
>> Cheated.
>> You would be pretty mad, right? Because
there was no what?
>> Justice.
>> No justice. No justice whatsoever. And
God is 100% just.
But God is also 100% gracious. Tough to
be both.
>> So God took upon himself
the penalty and he paid the price and he
died. Does he require your death also?
Now there's a trick question for you.
>> Yes.
>> Yes, he requires your death. What kind
of death does he require?
It requires the death of the old man of
>> sin.
In other words, the old you must die
and a new new must rise from the dead in
Christ through his power and his
resurrection.
And the new man is transformed. He's a
transformed man. And in Christ, we walk
this road again. We walk this road
again. And Christ gives us the strength
to do what is right. Wow. We have a
second chance. We have a second chance.
Now, if this murderer is sentenced to
death
and he completely repents and there he
sits and somebody is willing to exchange
places for with him
and he has a second chance, what would
he do? Run out and murder or would he
perhaps consider, "Wow, I have a chance.
I better walk straight." Walk straight.
So God forbid that grace should do away
with keeping the law. Therefore, by the
deeds of the law shall no flesh be
justified in his sight. We're not saved
because of any good thing that we do.
For by the law is the what?
>> The knowledge of sin. Romans 3:1 19 and
20. So the law cannot save me. Only
Jesus can save me. But the law can tell
me what's right and wrong.
So if I know what is right and I do it
not, what was that text we read? Then it
be for me what?
>> Sin. Okay. So the law tells me what sin
is. Romans 3:31. Do we make void the law
through faith? What does he say? God
forbid. Yay, we establish the law. You
know, it's amazing how Paul is distorted
on this particular point because people
believe that we are under grace and
keeping the law. That was a Jewish
thing. No, no, no, no, no, no. The Bible
teaches that we are under grace and that
works cannot save us. We can do what is
right as much as we like. If we don't
accept the free gift of salvation in
Christ, it's meaningless because only in
a person there's salvation in Jesus
Christ. But the law teaches me what is
right and wrong. And when I come into
harmony with Christ, I will keep his
commandments. Jesus says, "If you love
me, keep my commandments."
Romans 3:31,
"Wherefore the law is holy and the
commandment holy and just and good."
Romans 7:12.
So the Bible clearly teaches that the
cross does not take away the law. It
establishes the law. It establishes the
authority of the law. Because had it
been possible to take it away, Christ
need not have died.
Therefore, there is now no condemnation
to them which are in Christ Jesus, who
walk not after the flesh, but after the
spirit. Romans 8:1. Does the spirit like
sin?
Nope. The spirit does not like sin. So,
if you are in Christ, you say, "Lord, I
long to do your will. Show me what is
right and what is wrong." And walk
therein. Walk therein. Sin broke the
relationship
for Adam and his wife. The Lord God made
coats of skins and he clothed them.
Genesis 3 21. Here they had lost their
robe of right righteousness.
And God in his mercy says, "I will cover
you again." And he gives them the
promise of the Messiah. And he covers
them with his righteousness.
So the first symbol of death
was an animal that died. Right or wrong?
Yes. An animal died and it became a type
of Christ who would die for us. Now
let's have a look at another law which
is called the ceremonial law and it
pertained to all the festivals and rules
and regulations that Israel had to keep.
Now remember the ten commandments were
written how we read it? By the finger of
God. It was written on stone. And where
were they to be placed?
>> In the ark.
>> In the ark. The ceremonial law was
written by Moses and placed beside the
ark. Let's read that carefully.
Deuteronomy chapter 31. And it came to
pass when Moses had made an end of
writing the words of this law. Who's
writing now?
>> Moses. In a book, not on tablets of
stone
until they were finished. that Moses
commanded the Levites which bear the ark
of the covenant of the Lord,
saying, Take this what? Book of the law,
and put it in the side of the ark of the
covenant of the Lord your God, that it
may be there for a witness against thee.
Now, remember that carefully. Engrave
it. It's good to engrave God's word.
What must be there? the book of the law
and it serves as a what? Against us? A
testimony against us. A witness against
us.
So this law tells us something about
ourselves. Right or wrong? It tells us
you are sinners. The law, the ten
commandments tells us what sin is.
But this law tells us our part in this
and it points us to the solution. It
points us to the solution. There are two
separate laws. So the one was the
tablets of stone was placed in the ark
written by the finger of God. The other
was written on a scroll. The book of the
law placed beside the ark. Now the moral
law in the Bible, the ten commandments
in James is called the royal law.
It's called the law of liberty. Not the
law of bondage. The law of liberty.
I'll tell you something. If everybody on
this planet kept the ten commandments,
we would be free indeed. Did you know
that?
>> Because you could walk outside and you
can get into your car. You don't have to
turn a lock. You don't have even turn
the ignition. Just put your foot down
and go. You wouldn't need a key. And you
would have to have no fear at night. Not
look left nor right nor anything. Nobody
will come and clobber you over the head.
You would be free if everybody kept the
law of God. Right or wrong?
>> Okay.
Exodus 31 says it was written with the
finger of God on stone. Deuteronomy says
it was placed inside the ark. 1 John 3:4
to8. Romans 4 existed before sin.
Didn't it say where there is no law
there's no transgression?
>> Yes.
>> And Adam and Eve transgressed. So there
must have been a law. Right or wrong?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Romans says the purpose is to
reveal what sin is. By the law is the
knowledge of sin. Deuteronomy 5:22 and
Psalm 19:7 and Romans 7 and many, many
others. It is complete. It is perfect.
It is holy. It is just. It is good.
That's what he said about the law of
God. And Psalms 111:7 and 28 says, "It
shall stand forever."
Let's look at the ceremonial law. It's
called the law of commandments contained
in ordinances. Ephesians 2:15, Hebrews
9:10. It was written by Moses.
And it was put in a book of the law.
Deuteronomy 31. We just read that it was
placed beside the ark, not in the ark.
Deuteronomy 31:24-26.
And it was given after sin.
After sin. Galatians 3:19. The law was
added because of transgression.
So transgression requires a law. So
another law was added because of
transgression. So we have two laws. The
one is the ceremonial. The other one is
the moral. And the purpose was to reveal
the remedy for sin. Leviticus 616-7,
John 7 and29, and Matthew 27:51.
It's temporary. It will be done away
with.
Now, we must know very well what we're
dealing with here. We must know these
two sides of the story because in the
Bible, they talk about the law. And you
have to figure out from the context, is
it the moral law or is it the ceremonial
law? Tricky. And you can get very
confused if you don't know exactly what
this definition is. You have to know it
exactly. So that's what it looked like.
There was the moral law. It was inside
and uh above it was a gold sheet which
was called the mercy seat. Oh, wonderful
stuff. I'll come to it just now. And
then the book of the law written by
Moses with all the laws of ceremonies
placed inside it.
Now, there are four gospels written in
the Bible. It's the Gospel of Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. People say, "Why
is everything being repeated? What's the
point?" Well, there's lots of points
because each one is slightly different.
Matthew talks about Christ the King.
Mark talks about Christ the servant.
Luke talks about Christ the man. And
John talks about Christ the divine. So
here you have all the aspects of the
godhood. Now let's take a look at the
five books of Moses and let's have a
look at those.
Genesis
is the book of origins, the fall and the
promise of redemption. So Christ is in
that.
Exodus,
Christ our sanctuary. And we'll be
dealing with that. Wow, it's beautiful.
Leviticus, Christ our sacrifice, the
lamb of God that taketh away the sins of
the world. The lamb stood for who?
>> Stood for Christ.
So Leviticus is Christ our sacrifice.
Numbers is Christ our guide. And
Deuteronomy is Christ our reward. So the
first five books of the Bible give you
the plan of salvation in a nutshell.
tells us about the law and the
ceremonial law tells us about the remedy
for sin. And since the remedy lies in a
person, all these issues deal with one
individual only and that is Jesus
Christ.
Let's see if we can find that.
Genesis 26:5.
Fascinating text. because that Abraham
obeyed my voice and kept my charge, my
commandments, my statutes, and my laws.
Hello.
There are people that say that the
commandments belong to the Jews
and they were given at Sinai on the ten
commandments on the tablets of stones.
Right or wrong?
>> Well, what laws and statutes and
commandments did Abraham keep? That was
before the Jews.
Obviously, he kept the commandments of
God. So, all right, the commandments
were there. They were there from the
beginning. But because mankind is so
forgetful, they were given in stone
again to posterity.
And Jesus said, "I have kept my father's
commandments and abide in his love."
Jesus sets the example. He kept the
commandments. Jesus says, "Think not
that I have come to destroy the law."
He's referring there to the whole pentat
which is what the first five books of
the Moses but they contain the law of
ten commandments.
So not one jot or one tit will be
removed that includes the ten
commandments all the prophets everything
that has been said by the prophets I've
not come to destroy but to fulfill.
For verily I say unto you, till heaven
and earth pass, not one jot or one tit
shall in no wise pass from pass from the
law till all is fulfilled. Matthew 5:17
and 18. So you see Jesus didn't come to
change anything.
He came to fulfill it. He is the
fulfillment
of the ceremonial law. He is the
solution to sin.
And he came because the law of ten
commandments had condemned all of us to
death. And he came to do justice to pay
the price. So at the cross justice and
mercy kissed each other. Wow.
He says it is easier, this is Jesus
speaking, for heaven and earth to
disappear than for the least stroke of
the pen to drop out of the law. Luke 16
and 7 16 verse1 17 you see that the law
stands yes or no
>> okay so it stands 1 John 5:3 this is
love for God to obey his commandments
and his commandments are not burdensome
some people say I cannot keep God's law
it's impossible
it's impossible I've had preachers tell
me that preachers tell me it's
impossible to keep God's commandments.
We don't have to keep God's
commandments. In fact, the commandments
have been done away with. I said,
preacher, give me your wife. I need her
tonight.
He said, "What do you mean?" I said,
"Well, there's no commandment which
says, "Thou shalt not commit adultery."
No, I didn't mean it like that. We said,
"Well, how do you mean it then?
How do you mean it then? Is it all right
if I knock your daughter's block off? Is
that okay?" No, I didn't mean it. So, so
you shouldn't kill. can run through
them. You know, they all want them, but
they don't want them. Isn't that
strange?
Either they're there or they're not
there. The Lord says his commandments
are not burdensome.
And being made perfect, he became the
author of eternal salvation unto all
them that what?
>> Obey him. Hebrews 5:9. Obedience. If you
have a gospel without obedience, you
have a half a gospel. It's standing on
one leg. It's going to become unstable
and it's going to fall. Now, let's have
a look at this. This should knock your
socks off. The law in the New Testament,
Matthew 4:10 or Revelation 19:10, "Thou
shalt worship the Lord thy God, and him
only shalt thou serve." Check it out for
yourselves. It's there. It's New
Testament. I'm not quoting Old Testament
here. 1 John 5:21, Acts 17:29. Little
children, keep yourselves from idols.
That's the second commandment. 1 Timothy
6:1, that the name of God and his
doctrine be not blasphemed.
If you look at Mark 2:27-28, Hebrews
4:4, the Sabbath was made for man, not
man for the Sabbath. Therefore, the Son
of Man is Lord also of the Sabbath.
Here, honor your father and your mother.
Matthew 19:19, Ephesians 6:1-3. Thou
shalt not kill. Romans 13:9, James 2:1,
Thou shalt not commit adultery. Matthew
19:18, Thou shalt not steal. Romans
13:9, Ephesians 4:20, "Thou shalt not
bear false witness." Romans 13:9, "Thou
shalt not cover it." Romans 7:7. Is the
law there? Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> In the New Testament, yes or no?
>> Yes. Does it stand?
>> Absolutely.
Don't touch the law of God.
It was necessary for God to die because
that law stands.
Galatians 3:19. Wherefore then serveth
the law? It was added because of
transgression till the seed should come
to whom the promise was made. Who was
the seed? We discussed that just now.
Jesus.
And there was a law that was added
because of transgression. Now think,
ladies and gentlemen, think
transgression requires that there be a
law, right? So let's read this a little
bit differently. Let's say there was a
law added because of another law that
was transgressed. Is that what it says?
All right. Which law was transgressed?
>> The ten commandments. Which law was
added because of the transgression?
>> Ceremony.
>> The ceremonial law. Aha. Aha. So the
solution to the problem was added
because of the problem that was created
by the transgression of the law. Simple
as that. So here we had it from the
beginning. This one over here, his name
was Cain. He said, "I will not obey.
I will bring the works of my own hands."
There are so many people that say that.
You know that. Unbelievable. And Abel
said, "The Lord says, bring a lamb
because the lamb stands for the Messiah
who will come who will die in mystead
and shed his blood. And I trust in the
merits of the blood of the lamb. He was
saved by grace or by works?
>> So grace did exist in the Old Testament,
yes or no?
>> So how were you saved in the Old
Testament? By keeping the law or by
grace?
>> By grace.
>> Okay. So has anything changed?
>> No.
>> Nope. I am the Lord, I change not, says
the Lord. I am the Lord, I change not.
Let's look at the ceremony that had to
be enacted. Here is the sanctuary that
had to be built according to precise
specifications. There was a white wall
of white linen all around it. There was
one opening which was called the gate.
When you came in, there was an altar of
burnt offering. If you went further,
there was a labor. If you went into the
first chamber, the first tabernacle,
there was an candlestick. On the other
side, there was a table of showbread. In
the middle there was an altar of
incense. And if you went into the second
chamber behind that there were the ten
commandments in the ark with a covering
cherubs. That's what it was. Let's have
a look at this. Exodus Exodus 258. And
let them make me a sanctuary that I may
dwell among them. It was a symbol of
Christ dwelling amongst his people. As
Moses was admonished of God when he was
about to make the tabernacle, for see,
that thou make all things according to
the pattern, showed thee on the mount.
Hebrews 8 verse 5, everything according
to the pattern, not one chut, not one
title, don't move anything. It must be
exact. God is very exact. So he told him
exactly how to build it. Every single
detail and every single detail is
important. and nobody bothers to read
it. Oh, that was Old Testament.
But the Old Testament and what happened
was written for our admonition, says
Paul. So, we better make
sure when we look at it, well, all these
pillars, the Lord says this is a copy of
a tabernacle, a temple in heaven. And he
says, "Those that overcome, I will make
a pillar in my house." So the pillar
stands for the redeemed. Interesting
that there was money to be paid for the
construction and everyone had to pay a
redemption price. And it was the same
for poor and for rich. It was, if I
remember correctly, a quarter of a
shekele of silver and everyone had to
pay it. And Jesus sent his disciple to
fetch the redemption money out of the
fish of the mouth. Do you remember that?
And there was enough to pay for two of
them. Jesus is even willing to pay the
redemption money for you. But that was
the symbol, the socket. Everybody has to
partake, has to pay, has to give up
something.
And here was an outer gate, one gate.
And this gate had a covering over here
which had four colors in it. There was
purple in it, there was red in it, there
was blue in it, and there was white in
it. And then there was fine gold thread.
Purple is the color of royalty. Red is
the color of sacrifice. Blue is the
color of obedience. And white is the
color of righteousness. Those are the
aspects of Christ. And by the way, if
you want to have purple, you have to mix
red and blue. So sacrifice and obedience
makes for royalty. Wow. It is beautiful.
Jesus says, "I am the door
and nobody can be comes to the father
except by me. And if you don't enter
through this door, he says, you have no
part of him." So Jesus is the door. This
gate, there was only one. And then there
is another one over there. This one was
called the gate. That one was called the
door. And it had the same material. And
then there was another one on the inside
which had the same material, the same
colors. So Christ is identified with the
gate and with the door and the veil
between the first and the second
chambers. And when you came in over
here, the first thing you were
confronted with was the altar of burnt
offering. What happened there?
>> Sacrifice.
>> A sacrifice. And who does that sacrifice
represent?
>> Represents Christ. So the white linen
around it is the is the righteousness of
Christ. When you enter in through the
gate, in other words, you accept
salvation in Jesus Christ. You enter in
through the gate and you are surrounded
by the righteousness of Christ.
Beautiful. It's called justification.
And you stand before the altar of burnt
offering. and there is a lamb and you
witness the sacrifice of the son of God
in type to take away your sins. Hebrews
9 verse 24 says for Christ is not
entered into the holy places made with
hands which are the figures of the true
but into heaven itself now to appear in
the presence of God for us. So the
earthly sanctuary served just as a copy
of a heavenly sanctuary where Christ is
our high priest.
Hebrews 9:8 says the way into the
holiest of all was not yet made manifest
while as the first tabernacle was yet
standing. Christ's ministry in the
heavenly could only begin once the
earthly was completed. How do we know
that? Because in the earthly tabernacle,
the priest was not allowed to enter the
first chamber until the sacrifice had
been made. There was a lamb and then
there was a ram of consecration. The
lamb represents Christ at the beginning
of his ministry. The ram represents
Christ at the end of his ministry. And
if that ram of consecration was
sacrificed, the priest was permitted to
go into the holy place. And the Bible
tells us that Christ entered not with
the with the blood of sheep and goats
but with his own precious blood. So this
served as a guarantee of the coming
Messiah. Beautiful symbolism who serve
as an example and a shadow of the
heavenly things as Moses was admonished
of God when he was about to make the
tabernacle. It's a copy of the heavenly
hebrews 8 verse 5.
So the tabernacle pitched in the midst
of the people represented the ministry
of Jesus Christ. Now don't you think
it's important that we understand the
ministry of Christ? Yes or no? Yes,
>> I think so. Jesus in the midst of his
people. John 1:14. So, let's study the
ministry because if we study it, then we
will be able to discern many a deception
in the world out there. Many people end
their gospel once they've come through
the gate. Oops, there they are. They're
inside. I'm covered by the righteousness
of Christ. Life goes on as before.
Nothing has changed. No, no, no. There's
more to the ministry. You first face
that first tabernacle. Let's look at the
furniture once again. You come in, then
there was the altar of burnt offering.
Then there was the labor. And then you
went into the first chamber over there.
And in the first chamber on the one
side, there was the candlestick. Then
there was the altar of incense over
there. Then there was the table of
showbread. And there was the
candlestick,
the seven candlestick. And on the inside
there was this ark of the covenant. So
the court, the outer court represents
the earth, the gate, the door, the veil
represent the three dimensions of
Christ's ministry. Three dimensions, not
just one. There are four pillars for the
veil, four coverings, four colors, four
ingredients in the showbread. Four is
the number of the earth. North, east,
south, west. The whole earth is covered
by this redemption. 48 boards, 60
pillars, multitudes of 144,000s. The
sockets were made of silver, as I said,
made from the redemption money. For
other foundation can no man lay than
that is laid, which is Christ Jesus. 1
Corinthians 3:11. He is the foundation
of every single pillar. Five bars
holding the structure together. Five
factors holding the body in unity of the
spirit. Remember there is one body, one
spirit, one Lord, one faith, one
baptism, one God and father of all. Five
factors holding the sanctuary together.
Now let's get to the sacrifice. The lamb
was brought and the sinner was faced
with a lamb. What did he have to do? He
had to place his hands on top of the
lamb
and then the lamb was killed and the fat
was removed and burnt. Fat is a symbol
of sin. The burning of fat is the
purging of sin. Leviticus 3:3, Psalms
37:20.
So that fat which sits around the inner
parts surrounding the very internal
organs becomes a symbol of sin which is
burnt up in Christ. Beautiful symbolism.
The lamb was attached to the horns of
the altar. The lamb Christ is bound to
the sacrifice. He becomes your
sacrifice. So the lamb attached by a
cord to the horns of the altar and you
had to sacrifice the lamb. You had to
see that your part in it was you put the
lamb to death. The high priest catches
the blood. The high priest catches the
blood. And in a sense, the blood of the
lamb purges you of your sin. And the
high priest himself is a symbol of
Christ. Of course in this system the
lamb and the high priest are really one
but of course the lamb is dead after the
process. So the high priest represents
Christ who is in a sense the risen
savior.
Leviticus 4:27:31 and if anyone sin
through ignorance while he doeth
something against any of the
commandments of the lord then he shall
bring his offering and he shall lay his
hands upon the head of the sin offering
and slay the sin offering. We are
responsible for the death of Christ and
the priest shall make atonement of him.
Christ makes atonement for us. The
priest becomes a type and it shall be
forgiven him. There's the plan how to
get rid of sin. So you laid your hands
on top of this lamb. Let's read what the
Jewish Encyclopedia says about this. It
says the laying of hands upon the
victim's head is an ordinary right by
which the substitution and transfer of
sins are affected. In every sacrifice,
there is the idea of substitution. The
victim takes the place of the human
sinner. I have a question for you. Was
the gospel preached to them? Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> It was not preached to them like it's
preached to us, but it was preached to
them in type. If they had studied the
ceremony, they would have seen the
ministry of Christ, but they started
using the ceremony as a ritual.
And when you ritualize something, you
lose the essence.
So the high priest, the lamb, the blood,
everything points to Jesus Christ who is
the lamb of God that taketh away the
sins of the world. John 1 verse 29.
Behold him. Look at him. There's the
typology. It's fascinating
that Abraham was to sacrifice Isaac and
he was to do it on Mount Moriah.
Mount Mariah is the very mount where the
temple is built was built and the temple
stood for the sanctuary the ministry of
Christ. When they quarried Mount Mariah,
Solomon had the quarry made in Mount
Mariah and they dug out the blocks of
stone and that created a valley between
two hills and the one hill was called
Golgata.
Fascinating that Mount Mariah was one
hill and that Jesus Christ died on Mount
Mariah.
Wow. He died on the same mount
symbolizing the death of the lamb. My
little children, these things I write
unto you that you sin not. And if any
man sin, we have an advocate with the
father, Jesus Christ the righteous. So,
is Christ dead now that he died or is he
resurrected and is an advocate for us?
So, is Christ's work finished at the
cross or is he doing still something?
He's still doing something. Oh, yes. The
price for sin has been paid in the full.
But the work of Christ is not finished.
Otherwise,
it should have come to an end. Then
Christ is the advocate. We can still
find salvation in him. He was wounded
for our transgression. He was bruised
for our iniquities. The chastisement of
our peace was upon him. And with him his
stripes we are healed. If we confess our
sins, he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins. So must we confess? Yes or
no?
>> Absolutely. And to cleanse us from all
unrighteous. Do you know that there are
preachers who say that there is nothing
more wicked than we can do than to talk
about the sinful nature of man? I have
news for you. If we don't talk about
sin, then we don't need a solution. You
might as well go without Christ. Right
or wrong?
>> Okay.
So, all of these symbols stood for the
high priest. Now, here's the labor.
The labor came after the sacrifice. Many
religious systems come in, they want to
accept the righteousness of Christ. They
come into the door, they accept the
vicarious sacrifice of the cross, and
then they say, "Thanks a lot. Now I'm
saved."
But there's a washing to be done. Yes or
no?
>> A cleansing of rebirth. A change must
take place in the character. Something
must happen. So the labor represents the
washing by water. There it was. and you
washed at the labor. The priest did it
as a symbol. For there was a tabernacle
made, the first wherein was the
candlestick, and then there was the
first chamber, and the table and the
sobread, which was called the sanctuary,
and the high priest went into that
daily, not without blood. Now, this is
what happened. Imagine this. The sinner
brings the lamb, the lamb is slaughtered
and the entrails are burnt and the
carcass is eventually burnt without the
city, outside the city. And that
symbolizes that Christ would die outside
that he would be killed and eliminated
there outside the city.
Then the high priest would cook a
portion, a tiny ceremonial portion, and
the writings tell us that it was about
the size of a pee. He would eat it.
And in type, the confessed sins to the
lamb were transferred to the high
priest. Now he in type carries your sin
like Christ bears our sins. Now the high
priest did a sacrifice for himself plus
all the confessed sins that he had taken
upon himself and he took that blood and
he brought it into the sanctuary daily
and he put it on the horns of the altar.
So in type our sins have been removed
and placed on record in the sanctuary
and he keeps the light burning. The
light stands for Jesus Christ the light
of the world. This is a depiction of the
ark of Titus where he took the
furnishings away after the destruction
of Jerusalem and they carried these
things away. Where they are today, one
wonders. Jesus says John 8:12, I am the
light of the world. He that followeth me
shall not walk in darkness, but shall
have the light of life. oil that was in
the lamp is a symbol of the Holy Spirit
that would disseminate the life. So
through the Holy Spirit and the smoke of
the incense, the incense that was burnt
on the altar of incense which came from
the prayers of the saints ascended up
before God out of the angel's hands.
Everything dealt with Jesus. So the
priest burnt this incense and this
represents our prayers going up to God
being made acceptable through Jesus
Christ. And then there was this blood
that was transferred transferring the
record of sin to the sanctuary.
I am the living bread which comes down
from heaven. If any man eat of this
bread he shall live forever. And the
bread that I will give is in my flesh
which I shall give for the light of the
world. That was the table of showbread.
Bread without leaving, no sin. Now, in
other words, you came in, you were
covered by the righteousness of Christ,
you accept the sacrifice of sacrifice of
Christ. You must be washed by rebirth.
And then what must you do? Partake of
the light through the Holy Spirit. Jesus
is the light of the world. My word, thy
word is a what unto my feet?
a lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path. And if you do not partake of the
body of Christ, if you do not make
Christ part of you, you have no part in
him. And you speak to God through
Christ. So Christ becomes your personal
friend. You eat, sleep, and drink and
walk him. That's called sanctification.
And the Bible says without
sanctification, you will not seek God.
It's not enough to say, "I'm justified,
but I don't want any of the rest of it."
You got to take the whole package or
nothing. That's what it's all about. So,
the table of showbread represents Christ
for his people. There are 12 showbreads,
12 tribes of Israel, 12 apostles. The
numbers are significant. The ingredients
of the incense represents all mankind.
Hebrews 9:3. And after the second veil,
the tabernacle, which is called the
holiest of all. Now there we go into the
most holy. Now,
we've been talking a lot and maybe
you're smoking a little bit up here
already. So, shake your heads and go
wake up. You all awake? Great. Because
now we're going to do something really
exciting. We're going to look at that
second tabernacle. They say my hair is
all untidy. Who cares? Anyway,
the first tabernacle
represents your daily commitment to
Christ, partaking of the word, partaking
of the life, leaving living a life in
Christ. But it also contains the record
of all confessed sins. Is that
understood by everyone?
Because the blood was transferred to the
horns of the altar. Is that right? So it
contains the records of all the sins.
Let me tell you some good news.
Blessed are you if the record of your
sin is transferred and recorded in the
sanctuary.
Blessed are you. It's not bad news. It's
good news. Because those sins that are
recorded there are forgiven sins. Did
you know that all the sins that you have
confessed over the lamb and that have
been transferred to the high priest and
have been recorded in the heavens are
your confessed sins. So one day when the
record of heaven is to be purged and
cleansed from sin, they will open the
books and they will say, "Here is the
record of Walter Fight's sin."
And they will read a list so long it
will stretch 50,000 times around the
globe
hopefully.
And the devil will come and he will be
the accuser of the brethren, right or
wrong. And he will say, "I know that I
made that guy do this."
And they look up the record and they
say, "Yep, here it is. It says pardon.
Anything else?" But I know that he did
that. Let's check it out. Oh, yeah. Here
it is. It says pardon. And if he can
mention one that's not on the list,
you're in trouble.
So get your sins into the sanctuary.
Confess and forsake
and you will be safe. The judgment is
good news. If your sins are recorded in
the sanctuary now
in heaven one day,
I have good news for you. Christ's
redemption is so complete
that you will stand before God not as
forgiven sinners,
but as individuals that are as though
they have never sinned.
How far will God remove your sins from
you?
>> As far as the east is from the west.
That's infinitely far. There's no way
they'll ever get back to you. You will
stand before God as though you have
never sinned.
You will have a perfect right to heaven
one day if your record of sin is
recorded over there. It's the most
beautiful doctrine in the world. The
most beautiful doctrine in the world.
There's nothing to fear if you have
confessed your sins and forsaken them.
Remember Mary Magdalene? Do you remember
her? When she was accused, Jesus said to
her,
"I don't condemn you either." Is that
right?
>> That's grace. That's called grace. And
then he says, "Go and
>> sin no more." What's that? Putting her
under law.
So law and grace go together. So now the
record of sin is there and now once a
year the record of sin was cleansed and
for that purpose the priest had to go
into the most holy. What an ominous
situation. He had little bells around
him. Pomegranates and bells.
Pomegranates and bells. Pomegranates and
bells. And the bells would ring and they
used to tie a string to his leg because
if he went into the presence of a holy
God with sin,
he would die instantly and they would
pull him out from under the the veil
dead. That's how serious it was. So it
was a serious situation. The priest
would make full confession of his sins
and make sure his sins were all purged.
And then he went into the presence of a
holy God. He entered into the most holy.
Now there was the ten commandments, the
tablets of stone and the two angels and
the shikina of glory would appear. Above
the ten commandments which contain the
law of God condemning the sinner to
death if he's a transgressor was the
mercy seat. And the mercy seat was of
pure gold. And it represents the mercy
of Christ shielding you from the
condemnation of the law. Fascinating
story. You know that mercy sheet was 1
and a half cubits high and the grate on
which the sacrifice was burnt outside on
the altar was one and a half cubits
high. Little detail like that just
boggles the mind. In other words, God's
justice is as high as his mercy. Wow.
Anyway, here he would go in and he would
sprinkle special blood at the veil and
in front of the ark. It contained, of
course, the ten commandments. Great
peace have they which love thy law, and
nothing shall offend them. Psalms 119
165. Look at the furnisher furnishings.
There was the altar of burnt offerings,
the labor, and then on either side the
table of showbread and the candlesticks.
Then the altar of incense, and then the
ark. It was in the shape of a cross. The
cross and its shadow. Beautiful. Now
when these things were thus ordained,
the priest went always into the first
tabernacle, accomplishing the service of
God. That represented sanctification
through your life. Hebrews 9:6.
We have a high priest who passed into
the heavens. Jesus son Christ the son of
God. Hebrews 4:14. We have that
privilege today. We have such a high
priest who is set on the right hand of
the throne of majesty, a minister of the
sanctuary and of the true subtabernacle
which the Lord pitched and not man.
Hello.
Is there a tabernacle which God pitched?
Yes or no?
>> Yes. Well, either the scriptures are
there to admonish us and to give us the
truth or they are not. It says there is
one. So, I believe there is one because
that's what it says.
But Christ beingcome a high priest by
his own blood, he entered once into the
holy place having ordained eternal
redemption for us. Hebrews 9 11:12.
Christ is that high priest. The veil of
the temple was rent in twain from top to
bottom. The earthly sacrifice came to an
end. The ceremonial law was done away
with. Why?
Because it was fulfilled in
>> Christ. If I now take a lamb and I
sacrifice it today for my sins, what am
I saying? I've said this before
>> that Jesus's sacrifice was not good
enough. Now, the Jews want to build a
new temple and institute the sacrificial
system. Yes or no?
>> I want to tell you that's blasphemy.
>> Yes.
and their sins and iniquities will
remember no more. Now where remission
of these is there is no more offering
for sin. Having therefore, brethren,
boldness to enter into the holiest by
the blood of Jesus by a new and living
way. We have a new covenant with Christ.
It's the same as the old, but it's been
fulfilled in Christ. And I now look to
Jesus. I don't have to look at lambs and
goats.
I look at Jesus.
So the temple really
has been done away with and should
remain done away with. Time for a new
temple. They say so. I don't think so.
For Christ is not entered into the
holies made with hands which are a
figure of the true but into heaven
itself. Why build an earthly one if
there's a heavenly one? Yes or no?
Doesn't make much sense. All right. So
let's have a look at this interesting
service. So Christ was once offered to
bear the sins of many,
and he shall appear a second time
without sin unto salvation. Wherefore
he's able to save to the uttermost those
that come unto him. Everything the high
priest wore, all the clothing stood for
Christ. The inner garment, the white
one, the righteousness of Christ, the
outer one. Then the ephod, all these
symbols, the colors tying him to the
door and the gate and the veil, every
single stone, the 12 stones, the 12
tribes of Israel, everything refers to
the tabernacle. Even the roof of the
tabernacle. outside was an outer
covering which was made of badger skins
representing Christ's humanity and then
you have the colors that are associated
with the door. So the badger skin,
Christ veiled his divinity with
humanity, Christ the savior, skins of
rams dyed red, Christ the sacrifice,
covering of woven goat's hair, the
righteousness of Christ, and the inner
royal covering, blue, scarlet, purple,
Christ the worthy king, Christ the
exalted savior. Isn't it fascinating?
>> Wow. Now,
there were seven annual Jewish feasts
also associated with this service. This
was all written in the law of Moses.
There was a type and there was an
antitype. There was the Passover which
was the sacrifice of the lamb. It
represented the crucifixion. Notice that
it was on Nissan 14.
Then there was the feast of unleven
bread the very next day. Nissan 15.
That's Christ the body of Christ. Christ
in the grave. And then you had the feast
of first fruits which is Nissan 16. So
14, 15, 16, the three days, the Friday,
the Saturday, Sunday of the crucifixion,
it's the resurrection.
So even in their annual feasts, they
were celebrating the work of Christ.
Does that astound you?
Wow. And then you had the feast of
weeks, which was
6. There was 50 days thereafter. That
was Pentecost. It celebrated the giving
of the law, the tools of righteousness,
how to be right in terms of your
obedience. Grace comes from God. So now
they were fully equipped. At the same
time, they were sent out to preach
Christ, the solution to the sin problem.
The law defines the sin problem. Christ
is the solution to the sin problem. So
the cost of redemption.
So,
five trumpets, the feast of trumpets,
tishary was the heralding of judgments,
an advent movement, the day of
atonement, the pre-advent judgment,
tishary 10, and then the feast of
tabernacles going home. Now, let's have
a look at one of these. The day of
atonement, the harvest of redemption
would come thereafter. So, the annual
cleansing of the earthly sanctuary. This
is great stuff. the day of judgment.
That's what it stood for. So they blew
the trumpets
and they brought two goats and the one
was called
the Lord's goat and the other one was
Aazazelle.
It was
the scapegoat. But Aazazelle means
the evil one Lucifer.
So they cast lots and the scapegoat was
led into the desert and was not
sacrificed. He did not die. He was just
led away. But the Lord's goat was
sacrificed. So the blowing of the
trumpet is a symbol of judgment.
Revelation 14:67 Joel 2:1. And the
Lord's goat was sacrificed and the
priest entered with this blood into the
most holy. Remember the bells and the
rope tied to his feet. And Hebrews says
into the second chamber, that's the most
holy, went the high priest alone once
every year, not without blood. Leviticus
16:19. He shall sprinkle the blood seven
times and cleanse it. So this cleans the
sanctuary and hallow it from the
uncleanness of the children of Israel.
Remember all the recorded sins were
there and all of these had to now been
cleansed from the sanctuary.
And he shall make atonement for the holy
place. That's the first tabernacle.
Because of the uncleanness of the
children of Israel and because of their
transgressions in all their sins. And so
shall he do for the tabernacle of the
congregation that remainth among them in
the midst of their uncleanness. So the
whole thing was to be cleansed from the
record of sin. Unbelievable. So the high
priest took in the ceremony all the sins
that had been confessed for that entire
year upon himself and he came out and he
placed his hands on the scapegoat and he
pushed his hands on it and transferred
the record of sin. Who made you sin?
Who made you sin?
Satan made you sin. So if Satan made you
sin, this record is transferred onto the
scapegoat Aazelle, which stands for
Lucifer. And he will one day pay the
price for the forgiven sins. If you have
not confessed your sins, who pays for
those?
>> You do. Wow. Now, he doesn't become the
sinbearer because the Bible says without
the shedding of blood, there is no
forgiveness of sins. He's led into the
desert. For on that day shall the priest
make atonement for you to cleanse you
that you may be clean from all your sins
before the Lord. Leviticus 16:30. So in
the day of judgment,
you will stand before God with how many
sins on you?
>> None.
>> None. Isn't that astounding?
That is phenomenal.
Jesus's cleansing is total. You stand
before God as though you have never
sinned. Redemption is complete. Come
now, let us reason together, says the
Lord. Though your sins be like scarlet,
they shall be as white as snow, though
they are red as crimson, they shall be
like wool. If we confess our sins, it's
very important. He is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from how much unrighteousness?
All of it. 1 John 1:9. There are
preachers who preach the opposite of
this.
who say there is no greater damage that
can be done than to preach of the lost
sinful condition of man. We have to
acknowledge and confess our sins if we
want to be part of salvation. So it was
a time of final confession, a time of
cleansing, a time of judgment, and those
who did not partake were cut off from
the people. That's the sanctuary
message.
cleansing of the sanctuary. And he said
unto me, "Unto 2,300 days, then shall
the sanctuary be cleansed." Daniel 8:14.
There will come a time when Christ will
enter the second chamber and will start
cleansing the sanctuary. And we'll deal
with this 2,300 year prophecy at another
stage. Unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. So this judgment will take
place. The Bible says, "I beheld till
thrones were cast down, the ancient of
days did sit, the judgment was set, and
the books were opened. And behold, one
like the son of man came to the ancient
of days, and they brought him near
before him. He has appointed a day in
which he will judge the world." Acts
17:31. We better take note of judgment.
It's coming. 2 Corinthians 5:10. For we
must who?
>> All appear before the judgment seat of
Christ, that everyone may receive the
things done in his body according to
that he has done, whether it be good or
bad. So where would you like your sins
to be? On your head or recorded in the
sanctuary?
>> Get them recorded. The Lord will judge
his people. There's the list.
And if that list is as long
as you can imagine, then goody for you.
But if that list is one too short, you
could be in trouble. So examine
yourselves whether you be in the Lord.
And behold, I come quickly, and my
reward is with me to give every man
according to his work shall be.
Revelation 22:12.
The coming of the Lord will reveal these
things. I believe that we have nothing
to fear. The 2,300 days has a specific
time. It starts 457. If you add 2,300,
comes to 1844. It's an interesting time.
It's a very interesting time. It's the
time when the communist manifesto was
written. It was a time when the
evolution theory went out into the world
precisely 1844. It was a time when there
was a big clash between the Messiah and
the non- messiah. The music of the world
was written about the creation.
Wonderful time. Fear God and give glory
to him for the hour of his judgment has
come. What is the standard of judgment
going to be? Let's ask the Bible.
So speak and so do as they that shall be
judged by the law of liberty. The law is
going to be the standard of judgment.
James 2:12.
Let us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter. Ecclesiastes 12:13 and 14. Fear
God and keep his commandments. For this
is the whole duty of man. For God shall
bring every work into judgment.
Every secret thing whether it be good or
whether it be evil.
Do we hear much preaching about this in
the world today?
>> No.
>> Oh no. Oh no. If you love me, says
Jesus, keep my commandments. John 14:15.
Beloved,
if our heart condemn us not, then have
we confidence towards God. And
whatsoever we ask, we receive of him
because we keep his commandments and do
those things that are pleasing in his
sight. John 3:21-22.
It's as plain and as simple as that.
Ask forgiveness. God will place you
under grace and your record of sin will
be recorded in the sanctuary. Go and sin
no more. Eat the bread of life. Drink in
the water, the living water. Take the
light of the world. Live, eat, and drink
your religion. There's no good having a
halfway religion. And then when Christ
returns, you will be cleansed of all
your unrighteousness.
All of it. None of it will be upon your
head, not one stain.
And the righteousness of Christ will
cover you again. If we confess our sins,
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. 1 John 1:9. Repent
therefore and be converted that your
sins may be blotted out. This is a
gospel we never hear anymore. But this
is the truth, ladies and gentlemen.
This is the truth. Believe in the Lord
Jesus Christ and the shall be saved. But
believing
faith without works, without doing is
useless.
He that is unjust, let him be unjust
still. And he which is filthy, let him
be filthy still. And he that is
righteous, let him be righteous still.
And he that is holy, let him be holy
still. Revelation 22:11. Very shortly
that decree will go out and probation
will end. And if you are on the filthy
side, it's too late. You remain filthy.
If you are on the righteous side,
you remain righteous. And very soon the
Lord will come. The Lord is
longsuffering towards us, not willing
that any should perish, that that all
should come to repentance. 2 Peter 3:9.
I sometimes wonder when I look at the
world, Lord,
why haven't you come yet?
Some people say the Lord will have to
apologize to Sodom and Gomorrah if he
doesn't come quickly.
Because things are bad, but I know the
character of my God, and he is
longsuffering. And here is the patience
of the saints, they that keep the
commandments and the faith in Jesus.
Jesus is coming soon, folks.
>> Amen. He's coming soon with the clouds
of heaven. And it's my prayer that every
single one of us will have a right
understanding what it means to serve
him. It doesn't just mean to serve him
and sing hallelujah.
It means accepting him as my personal
savior and my king.
And a king is one who is to be obeyed.
Not because he wants to lord it over me.
No. The Lord Jesus demonstrated that. He
came to wash feet, didn't he?
>> Yes.
>> He didn't come to lord it over us, but
because it is good for us. Because it is
right for us. He says, "I will write my
laws into their hearts." That'll be the
new covenant. And when the law is in the
heart, you will want to do what is
right. You will want to do what is
right. I'll tell you, your relationships
will improve. Your love for each other
will improve. Your whole mindset will
improve if we come back into obedience
>> and an obedience relationship with God.
And there's nothing to fear of the
judgment if you have confessed your
sins. Nothing. And the longer the list
of sins, as I have said, that is
recorded in in the heavens, the better
because it means they're all there. And
forsake them and give them up. That's my
prayer for you. Tomorrow, we start
looking at the other side of the coin. I
have now done what I possibly can to
show you what the biblical criteria for
salvation and a relationship with
Christ, what they entail. Tomorrow, we
will look at the counterfeit. We will
identify the antichrist by name. And I
know that some might get hurt, but if
you are angry with me, be angry with me,
but not with a word.
You can throw a tomato at me, but come
back and eat more of the word and let's
see if we can get through this together.
Thank you for coming.
dancing.
Hey
Oh,
hey.
Wow.
W oh.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
go
down.